le nouvel an fêter comme il se doit à
travers le monde avec son lot de
cotillons de feux d'artifice le nouvel
an fêter aussi à montbéliard pour le
fameux réveillon des boulons à
strasbourg en revanche la fête s'est mal
terminée la ville a vécu les plus graves
incidents qu'elle ait jamais connue
depuis quatre la fin du monopole des
télécoms les opérateurs privés arrive
sur le marché avec on l'espère pour le
consommateur une baisse du prix des
communications
la contre attaque du ski alpin face au
surf on appelle ça des skis paraboliques
il tournait glisse mieux ce sera la
découverte de ce journal signé jean
jacques dufour et puis enfin un regard
en arrière avant de tourner la page de
97 une année riche en événements dans le
monde des arts et des spectacles avec le
sacre de juillet louis nauges couverture
du grand louvre la disparition de
barbara et celle de deux monstres du
cinéma américain madame monsieur bonsoir
est d'abord tous mes voeux pour cette
année 80 18 les miens et bien sûr ceux
de l'ensemble de la rédaction de france
2 l'année 97 a été enterrée comme il le
ce devait un peu partout dans le monde
avec son lot de record en record de
l'argent dépensé en allemagne pour les
feux d'artifice record des visiteurs à
vienne des blessés en italie du froid
sur times square à new york qui fêtait
également son centième anniversaire
à paris ils étaient 500 milles sur les
champs elysées la plus belle avenue du
monde entièrement réservé aux fêtards
richard binet
j -730 730 jours avant que l'an 2000
commence 730 jours avant le troisième
millénaire et sur les champs elysées la
liesse
cinq cent mille personnes venues fêter
l'année qui commence des parisiens mais
aussi une multitude d'étrangers l'avenue
la plus belle du monde était il ya soit
aussi la plus cosmopolite bonne année à
tous bonne année à tous les italiens
bonne année au monde entier même
ambiance hier soir à londres
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
londoniens se sont réunis à trapel 2
square
à new york c'était aussi la fête avec la
traditionnelle descente d'une boule
lumineuse durant les douze coups de
minuit écran géant
un show à l'américaine
sur la place rouge
on s'embrasse et on sable le champagne
même si les ukrainiens
hong kong premier coup de canon pour une
première année dans le giron chinois
tandis qu'en chine populaire
la nouvelle année était fêtée par un
gigantesque marathon sur la grande
muraille et pour le brésil
une année de musique et de feu où les
amoureux seront toujours les plus
l'ombre
elano endroits les plus courus en france
pour ne pas dire au monde c'est
montbéliard dans le doubs avec son
réveillon des boulons un réveillon qui a
lieu tous les deux ans mais dont
geneviève moll et bernie mériaux sont
entrés enthousiaste un beau milliard
on avait plutôt l'habitude de réveiller
tranquillement mais depuis quelques
années à partir de 22 heures le 31
décembre de vie ce temps boire fou c'est
à dire les machines d'inutiles défends
tu as envahi les rues
marché la parité durable et leurs règles
et partout dans les têtes et même sur
les têtes dans cette ville industrielle
tous les instruments de travail sont
détournés et les créateurs font des
prodiges
par exemple on mangeait pas besoin j'ai
fait avancer sa voiture en pédalant les
fans de la petite reine y sont aussi
enthousiastes que 6 assists et à
l'arrivée du tour de france
il y a aussi cette crèche se fait à
partir de toutes les pièces une
automobile depuis des copeaux de faire
il faut car dans en passant bien sûr par
l'électronique
mais il ya surtout dans les rues
d'étranges personnages sortis de
bestiaire fabuleux pour guider par un
crapaud hideuse une belle et la bête aux
déhanchements lascifs
ben bronze hiératique enfermé dans un
bout de bois tient n'est pas un des
personnages venus de contrées
imaginaires
une reine 9e lubrique sortie au loin de
mad max suivi de continuer farfelu
l'éblouissement pour des spectateurs
habitués au calme
je suis né à montbéliard je ne pensais
pas qu'on fisher une jacques carelman
d'état et
la route et à la deuxième heure de la
nouvelle année des dizaines de milliers
de personnes
ensemble partagent deux concerts
démissionnant de la drôme à 20 mètres où
tu répètes se réveillant des bouleaux
ces quelques heures volée à la poésie et
au rêve
et à londres l'une des villes les plus
folles et les plus prisées cette année
des français il y eut bien sur trafalgar
square et son célèbre rassemblement mais
la façon la plus typique cette année de
fêter le nouvel an c'était pour les
britanniques de se mettre à l'heure
française frédéric dupuy
la nuit tombe sur londres et sur l'année
tout est là pour un réveillon très
british bus à impériale bobbies
piccadilly circus
en fait vous n'y êtes pas du tout cette
année à londres le réveillant le plus
couru de toute la ville était surprise
le plus typiquement français
l'endroit où il fallait être le bal du
moulin rouge au café de paris
la jeunesse dorée londonienne et venus
s'encanailler
ge compte en plus me boas ambiance
cabaret les anglais en raffolent
réveillon c'est vraiment important
on doit faire une belle fête très
française très chaude et très sexy
beaucoup de gens sont très heureux ils
n'en croient pas leurs yeux le french
cancan et filles
beaucoup d'entre eux sont très british
ils n'y comprennent rien bientôt minuit
compte à rebours en français
le compte à rebours en français c'est
génial on n'avait aucune idée qu'il
était déjà minuit lâcher de ballons là
tout le monde comprend qu'il faut
s'embrasser mais les français bien sûr
le champagne s'étale anglaise avec une
paille
tueur se mélangeront jusqu'au petit
matin happy new year
et paradoxe des paradoxes à paris on se
met à l'heure américaine c'est le cas
surtout à montmartre avec la grande
parade des universités us
j'en fais yeux et frédéric bonnet le
premier de l'an à paris c'est pom pom
girl américaine ont choisi elvis presley
musiciens ici l'académie militaire de
new york majorettes la plupart venus des
écoles et universités américaines ce
sont 3000 participants qui ont défilé
cet après midi pour la sixième édition
de la grande parade de montbard le
défilé a emprunté les rues étroites de
la butte montmartre jusqu au sacré-coeur
une parade de deux heures et demie qui a
rassemblé un grand nombre de spectateurs
trois fois plus nous dit-on que l'an
dernier
je m'amuse beaucoup et je suis là pour
apprendre des choses nouvelles
uniquement pour vous amuser oui et
j'aime ça comment et paris aujourd'hui
très beau c'est super le soleil brille
et tout le monde est gentil ray depuis
deux ans les américains font une place à
des groupes étrangers ici par exemple
des portugais vivant à paris
côté français le secours populaire a
transformé ses bénévoles en mère noël
leur quête servir à envoyer des enfants
en vacances servi joli joli mais les
participants ont promis à la ville de
paris de revenir chaque année
ainsi la grande parade sera l'un des
clous des célébrations de l'an 2000 plus
calmement à rome le pape jean paul ii
dans sa bénédiction à attirer
l'attention des grands de ce monde sur
le sort des femmes et des enfants trop
souvent mal traitée à travers le monde
il a aussi appelé à plus de solidarité
et d'équité pour éviter que la
mondialisation ne mettent en marge des
personnes des groupes ou des peuples
entiers
le sort des exclus et des plus démunis
c'est aussi la préoccupation d'une des
plus grandes chanteuses américaines de
negro spiritual de gospel à liz mc comb
chaque année elle organise pour eux un
concert gratuit et cette fois la famille
coquatrix lui avait prêtés l'olympia
olivier d'el menzah et et philippe
chasselas
j'étais une petite fille poupe
issu d'une famille pauvre elle n'a rien
c'est nécessaire de chanter pour tout le
monde
l'artiste est une personne au service
des jantes un peu puis pan
bel honneur sirène
lise mâcon qui joue pour les sans-logis
les démunis
liz mc comb dont les ancêtres se sont
libérés des chaînes de l'esclavagé par
les seules forces de la culture de
l'espérance de la fois charles devons
montrer notre amour et l'a donné à tout
le monde pouvait être arabe juif chinois
japonais vous pouvez voter le pen je
m'en fiche
l'important c'est de montrer son amour
les esclavages la pauvreté revivre des
jours heureux au son d'une radio jacques
compagnons d'emmaüs a tout perdu sauf
l'essentiel la dignité de se trouver à
la suite d'événements assez douloureux
supporter ça à perdre mon travail et
j'ai pensé à diverses choses encore à
disparaître reconnaît que c'est très dur
c'est c'est pas évident à
j'ai nourri logé vie avec 300 francs par
semaine jacques amoureuse de liz mc comb
alors quelqu'un qui est connu c'est
formidable de s'intéresser à déjà à ce
qui est
et non parce que plurielle l'olympia
pour un concert unique
un concert gratuit
les volumes
il était normal
deux mille personnes ont obtenu leur
ticket d'entrée au concert de liz mc
comb à l'olympia 2000 billets distribués
par des associations caritatives de
mille visas pour le bonheur
la joie dans les coeurs 90 minutes de
chaleur humaine
liz mc comb une âme par nous tous les
anonymes qui peuplent sa musique
le mouvement des chômeurs l'occupation
des antennes assedic se poursuit dans
une quinzaine d'endroits en france à
l'exception de champigny qui a été
évacué arras l'un des bastions du
mouvement les chômeurs ont eu la
surprise de voir arriver successivement
pour se mêler à leur réveillon
alain bocquet le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée nationale et
marie christine blandin la présidente
verts du conseil régional du
nord-pas-de-calais and guéri et jean
claude elfassi un bref instant doumit
une seule nuit de répit minuit dans les
locaux des assedic les voeux d'espoir et
de bonheur ont remplacé les slogans de
lutte après 17 jours d'occupation ils
ont fêté le réveillon grâce au dos et
pour certains c'était le premier vrai
repas complet depuis longtemps
j'ai rangé mes débuts
c'est moi je n'avais pas arrivé on a ce
qu'on peut mais bassari d'entrée on va
dire quoi sur une petite salade en
entrée avec un peu de bayod disent tous
ça non on a le strict minimum couleurs
c'était des petits groupes et partir et
la maintenance est vraiment là sa grande
famille et c'est bien bien sentiment
joueurs parce qu'on serait bon vous avez
quinze jours de lutte ensemble on a eu
de la fatigue et ce sera un exploit
parce que demain on sait quand la mue
rebondir encore
etait-ce une promesse ou une parole de
campagne en tout cas hier soir un élu
est venu leur dire qu'ils étaient
entendus quand on n'a plus 20 millions
de chômeurs pecqueur il est temps que le
pouvoir le gouvernement le monde
économique les reconnaissent à part
entière à peine célébrer les douze coups
de minuit le réveillon un proviseur
prenait des allures d'une nouvelle manif
ça
l'autre évènement marquant de cette nuit
de la saint sylvestre ce sont les
incidents de strasbourg plus de 50
véhicules incendiés et des abribus et
des cabines téléphoniques détruits
la banlieue de strasbourg n'avait pas
connu une pareille flambée de violences
depuis quatre ans virginie fichiers du
nord au sud d'est en ouest cette nuit ce
sont tous les quartiers périphériques de
strasbourg qui se sont embrasées plus
d'une cinquantaine de voitures
incendiées triste record d'un soir de
réveillon qui laisse la ville abasourdi
dans les cités chez les habitants
l'inquiétude ou la révolte laisse place
à la résignation
je crois que ça normalement on est plus
en sécurité nulle part donc ça arrive
dans tous les quartiers donc c'est qu'il
ya un malaise quelque part donc et ça
quand est-ce que c'est s'arrêterait et
où s'arrêtera je ne sais pas c'est le
nouvel an ça leur fait plaisir
un rituel pour saluer la nouvelle année
qui a commencé dès 18h toute la nuit 400
représentants des forces de l'ordre ont
sillonné les cités et pourtant dans le
quartier de hautepierre une bombe
artisanale a dévasté l'entrée d'un
gymnase en plus des voitures en flammes
trente deux abribus ont été détruits
vingt-et-une cabine téléphonique brisé
des incidents qui n'ont toutefois pas
dégénéré
face aux forces de l'ordre ne l'est pas
eu l'affront
est arrivé à 80 reprises
qu'effectivement il ya eu les
fonctionnaires de police soient appelés
a avancé à proximité de groupe pour
inciter ces groupes à se dissoudre n'y a
jamais eu d'affrontement hormis quelques
caillassage clients vite et sans
conséquence ni nuit la banlieue
strasbourgeoise bascule un peu plus dans
la violence
l'effet tort ou aussi entre 97 et 98
ici pendant trois jours une centaine
d'ados de quartier réputé sensible à
préparer une toute autre façon
d'accueillir la nouvelle année oui
neuvic partie 3000 jeunes sont venus en
découdre avec la techno en début de
soirée beaucoup veulent encore croire en
l'espoir mais du fait ces jeunes du
ghanéen soirée au moins être un pas dans
la rue à [ __ ] le bordel au lieu
d'aller casser droite ils viennent ici
s'est amusé voilà zene espoire la rumeur
en q la piste des gans ceux qui sont
restés là bas
ces défis autrement il a pas tout cas pu
venir cette soirée plusieurs là qu'ils
ont pas les moyens de payer alors il
sait reste au quartier ils ont fait un
rappel cassé
les vois tu te fais pas ça veut dire que
demain
rien n'est gagné et demain qu'on
repartir sur le terrain pour
renouer le dialogue il faut pas que le
dialogue soit un petit peu tronquée pour
qu'elle soit un dialogue mais il faut
que demain on a en face de nous des
jeunes partenaires
ça a été le cas sur la ville partie donc
certains casseurs en tout cas le feu
d'artifice a été de courte durée
cette nuit douze d'entre eux ont été
interpellés ils ont entre 12 et 20 ans
et ce soir le procureur de la république
de strasbourg met en cause la préfecture
et la police je m'interroge dutil sur
l'efficacité du dispositif de maintien
de l'ordre qui a montré ses limites des
incidents du même type mais de moindre
ampleur se sont également produits près
de mulhouse et dans la banlieue
parisienne
hier dans ses voeux le chef de l'état
s'est inquiété de ce surcroît de
violence chaque jour at il dit les
limites sont franchies au delà desquels
la société se défait avant de demander
au gouvernement de restaurer l'ordre et
la sécurité est la première des libertés
réaction ce soir de françois hollande le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
l'insécurité est un problème préoccupant
ce n'est pas le premier problème le
problème c'est le chômage
il faut donc agir sur les causes même du
phénomène il faut aussi agir sur la
sécurité mais je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse faire de l'insécurité un thème de
politique intérieure je pense que la
nation peut se rassembler sur des
objectifs à la fois de prévention à la
fois aussi de répression mais je ne
pense pas qu'il soit bon et d'ailleurs
une arme ne l'a pas fait dans tana une
polémique entre les pouvoirs publics
là dessus c'est une tâche collective et
je mets en garde quiconque de vouloir en
faire un sujet de polémique intérieur et
françois hollande d'ajouter et
d'ironiser jacques chirac demande au
gouvernement jospin dit il de faire ce
que le gouvernement juppé n'a pas su
faire en 2e les principales promotion
dans l'ordre de la légion d'honneur pour
le 1er janvier on trouve les noms de
mireille mathieu sylvie vartan ou encore
sami frey des sportifs aussi avec luc
alphand et les navigateur loïck peyron
et laurent bourgnon et puis l'avocate
gisèle halimi ou encore la journaliste
françoise giroud depuis ce matin 0 heure
le monopole public sur les téléphones a
vécu en france c'est la conséquence des
directives de bruxelles
concrètement rien de tangible pour
l'instant puisque les opérateurs privés
ne sont pas encore prêt mais ça ne
saurait tarder et la concurrence salon
vise pour le plus grand pro
on l'espère des consommateurs gilles
mariné et eric de l'agneau jusqu'à
présent la concurrence n'existaient que
sur les appels internationaux
certains quartiers des grandes villes
ont vu fleurir les call box des
boutiques offrant des tarifs nettement
plus avantageux que ceux de france
télécom
les appels et en négocie auprès de
compagnies étrangères succès commercial
immédiat avec la fin du monopole public
tous les appels qui sont locaux
nationaux et internationaux seront
soumis à concurrence il y aura désormais
france télécom compris cinq sociétés sur
le marché
les appels locaux resteront dans le
giron du service public et sociétés
privées visant les autres types d'appels
chaque opérateur va proposer des
abonnements modique nous dit-on
correspondant aux diverses catégories
d'appel aux consommateurs de choisir et
de panache et il sera possible de rester
abonnés à france télécom pour le local
en confiant ses appels nationaux à une
deuxième entreprise et les longues
distances à une troisième les combinés
seront toujours installé par
l'entreprise publique
lorsque l'abonné voudra téléphoner la
connexion avec sa compagnie se fera par
le premier chiffre du numéro
actuellement le zéro chaque société
ayant ainsi un code d'accès cela paraît
un peu compliqué mais il reste plusieurs
mois pour s'y habituer puisque les
concurrents de france télécom ne sont
pas encore tout à fait prêt et
coïncidence le morse a cessé d'exister
le tout dernier message a été envoyé la
nuit dernière à minuit d'une petite île
de cornouaille à tous les marins qui
l'ont reçue disait simplement ceci bonne
chance et bon voyage le morse inventé en
1842 par l'américain samuel morse est
aujourd'hui obsolète et remplacés par
des techniques plus performantes
patrice pollet cette nuit le bip bip
pathétique du morse a retenti pour la
dernière fois depuis l'antenne radio à
la pointe de la cornouaille
un au revoir un dernier message une
série de points et de très sonore
inventé par samuel morse en 1842 un
procédé de transmission radio qui
permettra pendant de longues années de
signaler les catastrophes celle du
titanic
1912 par exemple à sos en morse qui
n'était cependant pas le premier
le premier souhait sans mort ça a été
envoyée depuis le ni ni rares à un
bateau échoué sur les îles scilly au
large de la cornouaille
c'était en 1910
en 1978 l'amoco cadiz fut l'un des
derniers à utiliser le morse pour
signaler son naufrage le morse qui au
fil du temps va laisser sa place
d'autres moyens de communication plus
performants comme les balises de
localisation gps vont le remplacer le
morse nous aura servi pendant de
nombreuses années
beaucoup de gens peuvent lui dire merci
mais aujourd'hui les techniques ont
considérablement évolué comme les
liaisons planétaire par satellite à
l'étranger politique bip bip ne
retentira donc plus jamais mais le nom
de samuel morse restera lui dans
l'histoire à l'étranger un nouveau
bateau chargé d'immigrants clandestins
est arrivé en italie près dorante de 30
dans la région des pouilles
le navire le cometa arrive de turquie il
aurait à son bord plusieurs centaines de
candidats à l'immigration d'origine
kurde
les autorités italiennes à s'apprête
donc à les accueillir comme elle l'avait
fait samedi dernier pour les 830
clandestins de l'ararat il faut dire que
l'italie demeure le talon d'achille de
l'espace européenne de schengen en
matière d'immigration faute d'avoir
aligné sa législation sur les autres
pays de l'espace schengen l'italie reste
une porte d'entrée possibles en europe
pour les clandestins
un simple lieu de transit d'où il tente
ensuite leur chance vers les pays
d'europe
les explications de gérard guilbert et
et didier da
cette carte d'identité est une
contrefaçon
on en vérifie tous les détails sur un
programme ultra moderne baptisé simbad
difficile donc pour des passagers
clandestins de débarquer dans un
aéroport un groupe serait vite repéré et
on a mis les compagnies aériennes à
contribution il faut savoir que les
compagnies aériennes au départ comme
trop le tour passagers afin de ne pas
être pénalisé à l'arrivée sachez que
chaque compagnie qui transporte un
passager qui n'est pas à rennes doit
payer dix mille francs damon dans ces
conditions le passage à pied des
immigrés clandestins est encore le plus
courant ici près de vintimille on peut
emprunter ce chemin pour traverser la
frontière entre l'italie et la france
longeant tout simplement l'autoroute
jusqu'à menton le sentier abouti à la
sortie du tunnel et en traversant
l'autoroute ils vont vendre en france
soit en italie des chemins comme celui
ci il y en a beaucoup mais on ne peut
pas mettre un policier sur chaque
chantier
chaque jour les autorités françaises
remettent à la police italienne des
immigrés clandestins
mais comme la loi italienne leur laisse
deux semaines avant de quitter l'italie
les immigrés retentent leur chance vers
la france ou l'europe du nord
voilà pourquoi l'italie et la grèce ne
font pas pleinement partie de l'europe
de schengen à l'intérieur de cet espace
il n'y a plus de contrôle systématique
des frontières en italie on a supprimé
les contrôles que pour les aéroports
supprimer les contrôles à l'intérieur
cela veut dire les renforcer à
l'extérieur la nouvelle frontière entre
les deux europes passe maintenant le
long de l'allemagne de l'autriche et de
l'italie ici à francfort sur l'odeur
la police allemande fait face à un
afflux de clandestins venus d'europe de
l'est offre proche des choses à être des
polonais il ya une très bonne route qui
est même à lauder il est facile de
passer le fleuve
et puis de notre côté en allemagne à
partir du village qui est là ils peuvent
être à berlin
en région parisienne le patron de la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
fait le bilan en un an 500 arrestations
de responsables de filières kurdes
s'ils gagnent ou chinoise pour lui il
n'y a pourtant pas de mafia sur le
territoire français plutôt une
délinquance organisée
une délinquance qu'on a connu jusqu'à
maintenant qui s'occupait plus tôt des
vols à main armée et des voiles
traditionnelles mais qui glisse
actuellement vers le trafic en matière
d'immigration irrégulière car ils
réalisent des profits encore plus
considérable cent mille francs pour un
clandestin venues de chine
cinquante mille francs pour un kurde
25000 francs pour un faux passeport et
gérard risbec me disais que en principe
au 1er avril l'italie devrait intégrer
complètement schengen à condition bien
sûr d'avoir fini de modifier sa
législation des cil 1 en ulster
une attaque d'un bar de belfast a fait
un mort et cinq blessés des catholiques
qui fêtaient le nouvel an l'attaqué non
revendiquée est attribué à des
extrémistes protestants dans le centre
de l'afrique 1000 à 2000 rebelles hutus
ont lancé une attaque contre un camp
militaire et une localité située près de
bujumbura au burundi
l'attaqué a été repoussée par les
militaire tutsi mais d'après le chef des
forces de sécurité burundaise
elle aurait fait au moins cent cinquante
victimes surtout parmi les populations
civiles
une première sur les reports de la
havane un concorde d'air france est posé
sur la capitale de cuba avec à son bord
une centaine d'hommes d'affaires anglais
venus prospecter dans l'île castriste
surprise fidel castro que vous voyez
était là en personne pour les accueillir
très intéressée semble-t-il par le
concorde point de s'installer dans le
cockpit et même de grimper sur une aile
le paris dakar c'est parti pour la 20e
édition un départ dans la tradition ce
matin à l'aube du château de versailles
avec une première arrivée à narbonne la
journée christophe du chien comme dirait
l'autre c'est pas gagné parce qu'avant
de penser à dakar il faut déjà partir de
versailles au petit matin c'est lé
démarrage pénible des petits motards aux
petites cylindrées
la moto et je les loue et ne
m'appartient pas j'ai un budget très
petit très serré 100% professionnel
stéphane peterhansel court pour gagner
et rien d'autre déjà cinq victoires une
de plus et il deviendra le moteur le
plus titré du rallye au départ le
paris-dakar réunis dans la même foule
les lève tôt et les couche tard ceux qui
l'aiment d'admirer les poids lourds ou
comme des camions des moteurs qui ont
déjà pris un pet au casque et les
vedettes du sport qui vole un peu la
vedette aux rallymen luc alphand sans
skis et marie claire restoux samson qui
m'honore mais avec son mari vous l'aurez
compris vu d'en haut le circuit de la
châtre dans l'indre 10h30 c'est la
première spéciale du dakar s'est voué
tendance rebbouh et et c'est un motard
amateur françois flic qui va s'imposer à
la surprise générale en revanche pas de
surprise générale côté voitures bruni
celli dossard 205 l'un des favoris
l'emportent dans un exercice où le plus
important finalement c'est de préserver
sa voiture
le dakar 97 c'est parti disons que là
vous c'était le hors d'oeuvre avant le
désert et comment glisse-t-on cette
année ailleurs sur les pistes de ski
c'est la grave question que se sont
posée au genre jacques dufour et bruno
girodon réponse on glisse bien le surf
est toujours en vogue mais le ski alpin
entamé une contre offensive avec un
nouveau matériel les skis paraboliques
pour décoller du réel oubliez newton et
les lois de la pesanteur les amateurs de
glisse sont prêts à tout essayer
ce qu'ils cherchent des sensations des
sensations nouvelles
justice pour faire plaisir mais aussi
pour trouver les fractions international
jeune génération qui peut d'opr
sensation du cheval sans le cheval et
vous avez pas une vie privée pour ça
pour ces amateurs de bonnes vibrations
il y a eu le monoski aujourd'hui
quasiment disparu des pistes le surf des
neiges et plus récemment le ski
parabolique ou carving de l'anglais to
card découper c'est vrai que ça permet à
les mains des skieurs moyen de découvrir
des sensations avec un skin normal il
pourrait pas avoir au niveau des appuis
coupé ou vraiment là on coupe la neige
on verra plus du tout bon grise et le
bipède l'imagination des industriels n'a
pas de limites des industriels obligés
d'innover puisque depuis 92 la vente des
ski alpin n'a cessé de diminuer
le car il n'est pas une mode c'était une
attente du marché pour des skis qui
procurait un nouveau plaisir plus de
liberté plus d'initiatives sur la piste
plus le sentiment de partager un plaisir
de neige sans contrainte
c'est un changement fondamental qui
durera et qui aujourd'hui prend
évidemment une ampleur tout à fait
spectaculaire puisque ça représentera
pour nos ventes plus de 60 %
c'est-à-dire plus de 800 mille paires de
skis vendus dans la forme des skis
paraboliques carvinois surf l'objectif
c'est la grâce aux skis mais on en a des
difficultés par moment donc on est mort
et quand on voit les surfers qui évolue
comme ça avec grâce côté surf justement
les ventes ont presque nous plaît on est
passé de 880000 unités en 95 à plus d'un
million et demi
l'année dernière le classique flexion
extension a du plomb dans l aile le ski
alpin le ski alpin je n'ai fait quand
j'étais très jeune qui est bon c'est
vrai que une fois j'ai lutté au srg plus
voulu quitter pour leur faire plaisir et
afin d'éviter les accidents
les stations sont désormais obligés
d'aménager des espaces réservés
c'est l'évolution des domaines skiables
il faut répondre à cette demande s'était
tenue clientèle sympathique jeune qui a
envie de jouer qui redonne un peu
l'esprit du jeu aux stations françaises
de sports d'hiver et je dirais que c'est
pas plus mal pour s'amuser justement la
dernière innovation ce sont des modèles
de skis courts qui s'utilise comme des
rollers skates chez salomon on appelle
ça le snow plaît
c'est la troisième fois seulement que
j'en fais et je trouve ça génial parce
que bon on peut s'éclater
on peut penser à autre chose avec les
son bled ça permet quoi des boss fait
rentrer les figures possibles failles et
des coûts profitant de ce petit virage à
360 degrés nous avons jeté un coup
d'oeil sur l'egypte du marché mondial du
site 12 milliards de francs
derrière la passion la saison du blanc
rime aussi avec argent
et un petit coup d'oeil en arrière
maintenant sur l'année des arts et des
spectacles une année qui a vu le entre
autres le sacre de juliette binoche
l'ouverture du grand louvre et la
disparition de barbares georges mélies
en 97 on a célébré beaucoup
d'anniversaires le 1er janvier déjà re
avait 70 ans toujours jeune et témoin de
son temps il aborde avec talent et
lucidité
le thème du sida le centre pompidou
illumine ses 20 ans et fait son
incontestable succès pourtant certains
n'en voulait pas de cette raffinerie au
coeur du marais je crois que seul l
erreur cette boîte qu'on prison ben oui
je nomme bout le monde peut se tromper
la cité de la musique à la villette
inaugure ses salles de répétitions et de
concerts
côté cinéma révélation d'un jeune
comédien des césar est attribué à
philippe torreton tel ou tel clan il
vient de la comédie française il excelle
dans tard puf et triomphe dans les
fourberies de scapin
ce n'est pas une révélation mais on ne
l'attendait pas dans ce rôle
uster joue cyrano c'est un bis c'est une
juliette binoche hollywood couronne la
française juliette binoche pour son
interprétation dans le patient anglais
37 ans après simone signoret qu'il avait
obtenu pour les chemins de la haute
ville
freemind les acteurs nous les aimons
dans le rire et dans la fête mais ils
nous font beaucoup de peine lorsqu'il
nous quitte
robert mitchum le nonchalant l'ironique
le prédicateur fou de la nuit du
chasseur s'en est allé un jour plus tard
james stewart l'élégant l'acteur fétiche
d'hitchcock a rejoint les étoiles
en ce mois de juillet le cirque aussi
est en deuil avec annie fratellini
disparaît une grande artiste et une
directrice d'école
on doit pas forcer un enfant à faire un
métier qui doit être encore une preuve
d'amour l'opérette repère un de ces rois
georges guétary
explosif extraterrestre michael jackson
en flammes le parc des princes
jean bichof la foule à blanc mais ce
n'est tout de même pas lui qui a mis le
feu au musée des monuments français au
trocadéro où sont réunies toutes les
répliques de l'architecturé ancienne
heureusement les dégâts sont plus
spectaculaires qu'importants au chapitre
des musées la ville de bilbao s'est vu
doter pour 1 milliard de francs d'un
musée guggenheim dont le bâtiment à lui
seul est une oeuvre d'art
il abrite désormais une exceptionnelle
collection d'art contemporain
pendant ce temps le louvre ouvre au
public les nouvelles salles consacrées à
l'art égyptien l'egypto magna est elle
en france que dès le premier jour trente
mille visiteurs se sont pressés d'aller
voir ces chefs-d'oeuvre pharaonique
c'est ce que veut mon temps
la longue dame brune s'est envolé dans
les nuages de novembre le grand chef
georg solti a lui aussi quitté ce monde
mais il avait auparavant distinguer une
jeune cantatrice roumaine qui fait en ce
moment les beaux soirs de l'opéra
bastille dans la traviata angela
gheorghiu
à
pourquoi
je vous rappelle les principaux titres
de ce journal sept jeunes dont certains
sont mineurs ont été interpellées à
strasbourg après les incidents de la
nuit dernière des incidents parmi les
plus graves que la ville ait connu
la fin du monopole des télécoms les
opérateurs privés arrive sur le marché
avec on l'espère une baisse du prix de
la communication
le paris dakar après un départ dans la
plus grande tradition à versailles et
une traversée de la france les
concurrents quitteront demain à narbonne
pour grenade en espagne
voilà bonne dans un instant la météo
patrice drevet avec un avis de coup de
vent et de tempêtes et les conseils
d'extrême prudence un homme est mort ce
matin près du croisic emportés par une
lame dans 20h50 à nouvel épisode de
l'instit de master 5 ans dans les 4
vérités emmanuel vanille recevra
historienne de christiane rimbaud je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur
france 2 je retrouverai à 21